bienvenido a la segunda parte de la
presentación de funciones en este vídeo
vamos a continuar donde nos quedamos en
el anterior de hecho todavía estoy un
poquito apenado por ese ejemplo de la
comida y de los vídeos fue un poco
extraño pero espero que te haya ayudado
en fin el chiste es que ahorita vamos a
hacer más problemas para que veas que
esto de los problemas de funciones
incluso hasta puede ser divertido bueno
este problema dice lo siguiente tenemos
la función g definida de la siguiente
manera gx es igual a iba a ser una
función definida por casos va a ser
igual a 1 si x es par es
y va a ser igual a 0 si x es impar es
impar
impar muy bien además de esta función g
vamos a considerar una función fx y ésta
fx está dada así como x + 3 veces g de x
muy bien ahora teniendo estas dos
funciones
imagínate que nos piden evaluar efe de 5
que tendríamos que hacer para obtener
efe de 5 a pues este 5 tenemos que
sustituirlo en cada lugar donde aparezca
x en esta expresión porque eso es
efe de 5 entonces vamos a hacer esto
entonces aquí está x tenemos que
cambiarla por un 5 y luego tenemos que
sumar tres veces g de y aquí hay que
ponerle g de 575 sale bueno ahora que
tenemos que hacer
bueno pues podríamos seguir
desarrollando pero primero tenemos que
determinar quién es g de 5 cómo le
hacemos para determinar g de 5 a pues
ahora metemos 5 en la regleta de acá 75
que sería pues bueno 5 espació cinco es
impar si 5 es impar entonces g de 5
de 5 es igual a 0 y por lo tanto aquí
tendríamos 5 más tres por cero esto
sería un cero y por lo tanto aquí
tendríamos cinco vale entonces
efe de 5 es igual a 5 pero ahora imagina
que nos piden determinar
efe de 6
efe de 6 bueno pues misma idea aquí
tenemos que sustituir x por 6 ponemos 6
más tres veces tres veces g de 6 ok esto
de aquí es igual a 6 más 3 por 7 6 y
ahora cuando es que de 6 pues una vez
más tenemos que ir aquí a la función g
vemos si 6 es paro impar es para
entonces estamos en este caso y entonces
g de 6 es igual a 1 vale entonces
quedaría 6 3 por 13 por 1 estrés así que
simplemente nos queda 6 3 que es igual a
9 muy bien creo que con esto ya vamos
agarrándole un poco más la onda a esto
de las funciones verdad es muy muy
sencillo simplemente si queremos evaluar
una función pues cambiamos pues cada una
de las equis que encontramos por el
número en el cual queremos evaluar bueno
vamos a hacer un ejemplo un poco más
difícil ahora con con tres funciones
imagínate que nos dan la función
x y nos dicen que es igual a equis
cuadrada más 1
nos da en la función de equis y nos
dicen que es igual a no se le voy a
poner 2x
efe de x 3 x 3 y finalmente nos dan la
función hdx y hdx es igual a 5 veces
pues 5 veces x + no nada más así 5 veces
x vale entonces ahora tenemos tres
funciones vamos a resolver algunos
problemas
imagínate que nos piden encontrar pues
no sé vamos a ponerle h déjame agarrar
otro color un poco más bonito voy a
agarrar este azul entonces imagínate que
nos piden determinar h
de g de 3 ok esto ya se ve un poco más
complicado verdad basta decir cómo le
hago para encontrar h deje de 3 bueno
pues vamos paso a paso lo primero que
tenemos que hacer es determinar g de 3
entonces eso es lo primerito como ya
hacemos para encontrar g de 3 pues nos
vamos a la definición de g y tenemos que
sustituir las x todas las que aparezcan
por un 3 entonces esta x que hace 3 está
aquí se hace 3 y estar acá también
entonces nos quedaría a ver de 3
es de 3 es igual a 2 por 3 2 por 3 de 6
más
efe de 333 menos 30 así que sería efe de
0 todavía no terminamos con determinar g
de tres porque ahora tenemos que ver
quién es
efe de 0 para sustituirlo aquí entonces
ahora nos vamos a efe vamos a la
definición de f sería 6 más y quiénes
efe de cero pues es elevar al cuadrado
el número es x al cuadrado y sumarle 1
nos quedaría 60 más 1 y entonces g de
tres es igual a siete vale ok entonces
xerez 3 es igual a 7 y bueno ahora con
esto ya podemos poner gt3 acá nos
quedaría hd7 hd7 y hd7 lo podemos
calcular directamente nos vamos aquí h
de 75 por 7 por lo que es lo mismo 7 por
5 que es igual a 35 vale entonces
parecía un poco complicado esta
expresión pero simplemente lo fuimos
haciendo por cachitos aquí adentro
teníamos un g de 3 hacemos primero sg de
3 para eso nos vamos a la expresión de g
ponemos aquí el 3 nos queda 2 por 36
pero luego hay que ver quién es efe de 3
menos 3 o sea f de 0
efe de 0 y bueno viendo efe nos queda
que efe de cero es 1 y por lo tanto es 6
más uno que nos da 7 bueno vamos a hacer
otro ejemplo más
de hecho ya no tengo tanto espacio abajo
vamos a hacer otro ejemplo con estas
mismas funciones vale de hecho eso hasta
ayuda porque así no tenemos que sacar
nuevas funciones y no va a ser tan
confuso bueno entonces vamos a hacer
otro ejemplo con estas mismas funciones
entonces imagínate que nos piden
determinar
efe efe efe de h de 10 por decir algo
vale entonces
efe dh de 10 misma idea lo primero que
tenemos que hacer es determinar quiénes
h de 10 lo que está dentro del
paréntesis pues más más interno vale
entonces h de 10 cuando es hd x es 5x
entonces h de 10 5 por 10 por lo tanto h
de 10 perdón hd si h de 10 h de 10 es
igual a 50 entonces aquí nos quedaría
efe de 50 vale y luego quienes efe de 50
pues el 50 lo ponemos acá nos quedaría
50 al cuadrado más 150 al cuadrado es
2500 y por lo tanto el resultado
2500 1 vale 2501 este estuvo fácil vamos
a hacer uno más no sé imagínate que nos
piden determinar
nos piden determinar g de h de uno va
entonces gd hd1 de hecho hay dos formas
en las cuales podríamos hacer esto
primero usando la definición de g y
luego la de h pero vamos a hacerlo así
como lo estamos haciendo empezando con h
entonces tenemos que ver quién es hd 1
esto sería igual a g de y haber hd 1 hd
1 es 5 por 1 entonces es igual a g de 5
muy bien ya nada más tenemos que ver
quiénes xerez 5 entonces g de 5 es igual
a nos vamos aquí g de 5 es 2 por 5 que
sería 10 más
efe de 5 menos 35 menos 32 entonces no
quedaría más
efe 2 y por lo tanto esto sería igual a
10 más vamos a ver quiénes f2
efe 2
es igual a 2 al cuadrado que es 41 se a
efe de 12 5 sería 10 + 5 y por lo tanto
el resultado es igual a 15 excelente
bueno no te preocupes si todavía estás
confundido en los siguientes vídeos voy
a agravar todavía más ejercicios para
que podamos ir aprendiendo más acerca de
las funciones bueno nos vemos hasta la
próxima